[Music]
more taco war Cody Moody
[Music]
we're currently working on the sport and
recreation plans for the Khoikhoi yeast
regeneration area and we've been meeting
with the sports clubs they're going to
be located here during this design phase
we're looking at positioning for the
sports fields car parking changing
facility public toilets and also spaces
for the BMX track and dog park the
cowboy food forest was a popular request
during the development of the recovery
plan in September a number of mature
fruit trees from empty sections and the
regeneration areas were relocated to the
food forest site and then the community
lead project really got off the ground
with the opening and community planting
it was number one request on all the
community consultation and it's just
great to see something visible and above
ground happening it's always more
exciting to plant trees than put sewer
lines underground and the community of
tuned out in force and it's all go many
of the trees planted were donated from
groups and tree nurseries located from
all across Canterbury organizers were
stunned by the support shown by the
community we've had amazing support for
the carboy food forest so many groups
have come down so kaya Boyd Garden Club
we've got cactus the Leadership Program
from Park we hi we've got the mayor
we've got councillors we've got what
probably 150 odd bit other mentioned
Leslie I'm running out of fingers to
count
although a large amount of work is being
done it will take years for the project
to come to full fruition the food first
has been planted in a layered system
with larger fruit trees sheltering
smaller bushes and plants it's quite a
lot of work intensive work initially for
the first couple of years so you said
that that made you a fruit tree up or a
nut tree and then underneath that you
put a smaller fruit tree and underneath
that you put raspberries or berries then
underneath that root crop end and ground
cover so you've got five layers over the
top of each other and the food forest
isn't just about providing food it's
also an opportunity for the community to
connect with one another I think this is
something that's lacking is if there's
people getting out and working with each
other and and spending time with each
other so me it's not necessarily so much
about a food forest it's about
everything else that goes with it it's
incredibly humbling and what an amazing
community to be part of thanks everyone
the food folks will really be coming
into its own in about March next year
and the public will be able to come down
and enjoy it we'll be installing a new
pedestrian gate mixing the existing gate
on Castro
and the next update will meet Gavin Lake
the council's roading recovery program
manager he's supervising to roading
projects that kick off in January a new
road linking Kai for East and inquire
for self the repair of Courtney Drive
and parts of Chartres Street and why the
face for more information about the
regeneration visit any council service
center or Waimakariri govt te NZD Ford /
regeneration
[Music]